a former chemical engineer and
intelligence agent specializing in
counter-terrorist operations vivian
connelly seem like one of the most
promising newcomers as a division agent
so what caused it to betray her
government and not just joined forces
with a hostile faction but become their
leader
[Music]
[Music]
vivianne connelly possessed an
impressive resume much of which placed
her quickly in sights of the sh t
recruiters as a chemical engineer she
had learned how to develop and design
chemical manufacturing processes another
valuable set of skills included her work
as a counterterrorism agent where she
incorporated military tactics techniques
and strategy to neutralize terrorists
and their organizations however not
everyone was convinced that she was the
right fit for the role of the division
agent tendencies for fixation and
obsession well that's exactly what we
want in an agent so I'm gonna gets
obsessed with a target and goes after
them regardless of the collateral or she
will just commit to the mission fixation
and obsession can be a good thing you
just like her because she's a techie hey
we need people who are willing to think
outside of the box and we need more
people that can fix our [ __ ] when it
breaks she's resourceful and obsessive
the program will guide her in the right
direction and give her the right focus
she's smart capable and [ __ ]
brilliant we can't depend on continuous
training for these people to qualify we
need to have a standard from the get-go
what if they're activated tomorrow would
you be comfortable having Conley out
there I would no question all right for
the next phase during the vien psych
evaluation a number of concerns were
highlighted in regards to her extreme
obsessive behaviors which could have the
potential to cause a number of problems
while out in the field but like so many
before she was pushed through regardless
of the fears and given the go-ahead to
progress to the next stage of
recruitment not long after the green
poison outbreak Conley was activated as
a first wave agent and deployed him to
midtown Manhattan to assist the JTF in
securing the quarantine zone shortly
after activation the Joint Task Force
was ordered to stop and move out of the
area leaving Connelly and the other
division agents to complete the
assignment on their own as the agents
struggled with the seemingly impossible
task eventually a number of them are
killed by the growing hostile presence
while others succumb to the virus itself
and those who survived we're forced to
retreat I believe weak people will
always make bad choices when they're
scared hey you want some help
not on this one you only get in my way
that was right a territory
fortunately for Connelly she was one of
the few that managed to get away however
sadly for her she was about to find out
that her own family
it just becomes some of the latest
victims of the dollar flu
mad with grief Conley needed sone to
blame someone needed to pay for this
incompetence and miss handling of the
crisis she decided to focus her anger
solely on the government and the
obedient jdf soldiers who'd blindly
followed their orders but eventually
even she would get caught up in the
chaos and found herself in the middle of
a hot zone that resulted in her becoming
trapped under a pile of rubble caused by
an explosion from a nearby building
she's one of those ring and all hey Jo
wanna talk to her hey don't try anything
now I'm just gonna take that little gun
of yours be my guest
I can't wait to see this show of yours
well out on a foraging mission a group
of cleaners found calmly trapped and
proceeded to take it back to their
leader Joe Farah already flaked his
rogue at this point she was interested
to can see what Pharaoh had to say
before long she found herself among a
group of ex sanitation workers and
contractors and these guys were taking
matters into their own hands just like
herself they too were feeling the pain
of loss and abandonment after the JTF
lived them behind and Conley
understandably took comfort with these
people and their plans to eradicate the
virus so unsurprisingly not long after
meeting them she joined their ranks
immediately she went to work putting a
previous experience as a chemical
engineer to use she started upgrading
their weapons and training them in the
basics of military combat the cleaners
quickly accepted her guidance and had
already begun talking about her as a
potential successor to Joe Farah one day
do we still need Joel don't [ __ ] say
that I know I know he started the whole
movement and he's taking care of us but
ever since Vivian came on I feel like
Joe's doing less and she's the one
actually steering the ship she's an
asset yeah but there's no question she
also answers to Joe we all do so shut
your [ __ ] mouth and fall in my hole
of course I didn't mean nothing by it
but you know Joe's not gonna be around
forever he will need someone to fill his
shoes the way I see it Connolly is the
best choice right obviously but not
another bad word about Joe or I'll throw
you into the fire months pass the
activation of the second wave of
division agents made the cleaners were
pushed right back which eventually
provoked Joe Farrell himself to get
involved and trying to put a stop to the
invading government forces but he was
quickly overwhelmed by the agents upon
ferry's death Connelly took over as his
successor and quickly regrouped her
scattered forces from there she began
the restructure and reorganization of
them into a group of individuals that
would eventually become even deadlier
than before because of the division the
cleaners had taken a heavy hit along
with killing their leader the one had
started at all their resources and fuel
had taken a hit and we're running
incredibly low but calmly at the scene
was coming and had already scouted ahead
to find the ideal solution to their
problems few weeks we've been draining
every deposit in Midtown but we're gonna
use it all eventually in Midtown yes
we're gonna have to migrate and abandon
everything we've built there's a
stranded oil tanker on the Lower East
Side it crashed into two bridges during
the hurricane when oil in it I'm not to
laugh at least eight months a year if
we're smart that's unbelievable
went down there myself the crews go on
board but we can take care of that no
one else has claimed it yet it should be
a cakewalk put a strike team together
we'll head down there tonight and take
care of the crew once the site's secured
I'll give a green light for backup
then we'll have a refinery up and
running in a few days yes ma'am
Conley made the call to relocate the
cleaners operation to southern Manhattan
there they could set up shop and begin
rebuilding their ranks Conley set the
task of taking over the ship and setting
it up as a refinery in order to fit the
heavy need of fuel for the upcoming
battles
Conley's successes soon caught up with
her so when she hadn't seen since the
JTF first pulled out of the quarantine
zone came knocking checking in on you
you seem to be doing okay more than okay
these guys have their priorities
straight this [ __ ] isn't going to be
sorted out unless we take full measures
well they're very principled and
uncompromising I'll give you that what
do you want here look you need to think
bigger the cleaners are gonna solve this
on their own
you need help leverage and that would be
you got some friends I'm putting
together something special we are going
to save the city no matter the cost free
from disease and corruption take down
the JTF and the division for good and
where do we fit into that
well for starters are you familiar with
a man named Vitaly it's your neck Oh
rogue agent Aaron Tina came to calmly
offering a partnership well hesitant to
work with Tina her blind rage towards
the dollar flew and the promise of
information on the location of one of
the people who were responsible for it
the teletran Tenko was enough to
convince her to join his side kina would
later Quist that Connelly bring on
fellow rogue agent havea coochie-coo but
she wasn't interested she had heard of
chika and what he'd been up to and
didn't want the cleanest to be a part of
it Makino told her of his mission and
that kojiki could assist in removing the
JTF
who at this stage were the only thing
standing between the cleaners in the
goal Connelly reluctantly agreed Tina
provided Connelly with the details of
where training goes being held he
informed her that the LMB had been
holding him and had handed him over to
the black tusk after joining their ranks
Connelly ordered the cleanest to assault
the black tusks on Coney Island taken by
surprise and heavily outnumbered the
black tusks were quickly eliminated
however unknown to the cleaners the shd
had also found out about turn Incas
location and while the cleaners and
black tusks were preoccupied with
fighting each other they quickly moved
in and extracted the Russian scientists
while rogue agents parnell drag off and
catch iike cleared out the JTF guards
connelly was sent by kena to set up his
new weaponized virus charges in certain
areas of city hall the damage was
extensive division agents from
washington d.c arrived in new york to
investigate the attack
once there they quickly found that
Conley and the other rogue agents were
responsible for the attack and that they
were operating under Aaron kinas
guidance local peacekeepers were able to
provide Intel on Conley's whereabouts
and from there the agents were able to
locate the cleaners who were assaulting
an apartment building with Conley being
present however before the agents could
tear through the cleaners Conley had
escaped through Intel found within the
building the agents were able to
pinpoint where Conley had been residing
she was holding out in an abandoned
cargo ship on the shore of South
Manhattan the agents assaulted the cargo
ship head-on and were met by a large
group of cleaners battling
floor-by-floor
the agents eventually made their way to
the top deck and after flushing her out
by reversing the gas pipes they faced a
head-on
after a short encounter the agents
managed to take her down the Conley had
one last surprise as she dropped to the
ground screaming the set of explosives
she had strapped to her body detonated
with nothing left the Connally very
smart watch the agents collected the
watch and on their return to Haven
passed over to fail out who would use it
to help locate Aaron keener
over the fall rogue agents featured in
warlords of New York we can see that
kena was able to manipulate threaten and
bribe these originally unwilling rogue
agents and to doing his bidding
but as I've been heading it through
these last few videos this seems to be a
huge variation in criteria that has led
these agents to flaggers rogue on the
Isaac Network in the first place are we
still looking at Isaac as being the best
indication of what's rogue I hadn't
planned on making this video for a while
because we're still missing a good
number of collectables I think I still
have three more to collect but from the
last video there were a number of you
that have been waiting on this one so I
win and headed completed what it could
it may be the fact that I need to
release an update when these are found
depending on what comes up if you're not
already you can follow me on Twitter
with my lovely community hand I'll use
that term very loosely like to hurl
abuse at me on the daily I'm sure they
love me really otherwise thank you very
much for watching this and I'll catch
you in the next one
Cheers
[Music]